today on the matt walsh show we're told
of course that many unarmed black men
have been killed by police are killed by
police every year
this is a claim that is extremely
misleading on multiple levels and today
i want to give you the real facts about
that
about that claim also five headlines
including alexandria quesa cortez having
a temper tantrum
on the house floor because someone
called her a mean name she decided to
take uh
quite a bit of time to talk about the
mean name she was called and in our
daily cancellation we're gonna cancel
the football team in washington
as they are now known um they got rid of
redskins because it was offensive but
they replaced it with a name
that is even more offensive and that's
why they're canceled
we'll talk about all that coming up you
know i've already made the case that
systemic racism in law enforcement is a
myth um the claim that racist police are
prowling the streets searching for black
men to murder
is absurd on its face and then even
absurder
when you look at the facts um it's now i
think been pretty well publicized at
least in some corners
that despite all the panicking and
rioting over race-based
police brutality uh allegedly race-based
police brutality
only a very small number of unarmed
black men are killed by police each year
um but an even closer look at the data
and a study of of of each quote-unquote
unarmed killing
reveals that the real number of
unjustified police shootings of actual
unarmed people
black white or any other race is much
much smaller than it even first appears
now first of all um because this is
this is important to put everything into
perspective i think it's helpful to
begin with and i haven't seen enough
people do this
let's begin with the overall number of
arrests
now according to the doj they do keep
track of this information
and for what i found on the website they
don't have the exact information for
2019 yet but you can go back over the
last i don't know 20 years or more
and look at it uh so based on that you
look at an average it's
you could see that police make about 10
million
arrests every year of black white
um all races as a rough
average uh seven million whites and
three million blacks
are arrested or i suppose i should say
because there are gonna be repeat
offenders so
there are seven million arrests of white
suspects and three million arrests of
black suspects
uh now black apparently includes
hispanics by the way just by the way
they tabulate this information on the
doj website
um and that's that's how you get most of
the 10 million figures
now out of that number last year
25 unarmed whites were killed by police
compared to 14 unarmed blacks killed by
police according to the washington post
database of police shootings this means
that about
point zero zero zero four percent
of all blacks arrested were killed while
unarmed
um and that percentage for whites is
is pretty much exactly the same it's
it's definitely comparable
in total you've got a thousand people
who are shot and killed by police in
2019
the vast majority of whom were armed but
still that's a mere
.01 percent of all arrests
that lead to uh the killing of the
suspect
now the numbers aren't going to be
exactly the same every year of course
for example the post says that 22
unarmed blacks were killed in 2017
compared with 31 whites but the
percentage
doesn't change very much so that point
zero zero zero four percent is
is basically where we're at every year
now also we should acknowledge
that the numbers vary depending on what
source you use not everybody's going to
say the same thing us
usa today for example cites a
crowd-sourced
database um that has
25 unarmed black killings in 2019.
the post says 14 this this database is
25.
however you look at the individual cases
which is what you have to do
and most people you know don't have the
time or don't take the time to do it
this is one of the reasons why the
medias so easily can mislead us
um but you take that 25 number you look
at the you look at the actual cases
which i did
and you find that they count as police
shootings
any shooting involving a police officer
on or off duty
so violence stemming from domestic
disputes or
you know an off-duty bar fight between
two guys
this is gonna make it on to their list i
think i think that
clearly is not how you determine whether
there is a systemic
problem of racial bias in law
enforcement
we need to look at cases of uniform
police officers shooting
unarmed black people in the line of duty
we know that number is already quite low
but a closer inspection of the actual
cases shows that it's even lower than we
think
and this is really important because it
reveals that the whole category of
unarmed shootings is extremely
misleading
and i think intentionally so now i read
into
all 14 cases included in the post 2019
database
um a few of those cases were
straightforwardly unjustified
uh atatiana jefferson was shot while
sitting inside her mother's house we
talked about this case actually when it
happened
a few months ago and uh the officers
were
responding to a call from a neighbor who
who was concerned that there
that there might have been a break-in at
uh
you know at the house the door was left
open it was the middle of the night
i'm not sure if the neighbor saw
anything else that made them think there
was a break-in but
officer aaron dean shows up he's peering
into the into the windows
in the dark spots jefferson screams for
her to show her hands
doesn't identify himself as a police
officer so who knows what she's thinking
she could think that this is you know
who knows who it is
just someone outside of her window with
a gun telling her put her hands up um
she doesn't respond right away so he
shoots her now dean has been charged
with murder it's a
as i think as well he should be it's a
horrible case it's outrageous behavior
by dean
um but it hardly amounts to systemic
racism all on its own
and there's no reason to think this is
that this is even an isolated case of
racism there's no reason to think that
dean
was did this because he's a racist man
it seems that he could hardly even see
who he was shooting
which makes it which which makes his
behavior all the more egregious
because he couldn't even see what he was
doing and he's still shooting into a
house
but also it means probably not racism
officer carmen de cruz in texas fatally
shot a man named michael dean body cam
footage apparently shows it to cruz
accidentally discharged his firearm
while he was trying to dis
confiscate um dean's car keys during a
traffic stop
stopped him uh told him to turn the car
off i guess he was hesitant to turn it
off so then
uh de cruz tried to reach in he had his
gun drawn tried to reach in
take the car keys and accidentally
discharged
the weapon and killed dean um
and uh and he's being charged with
manslaughter for that
both of these cases are clearly
unjustified these are
obviously people who should not have
been killed it's a horrible tragedy
both of the officers receive criminal
charges appropriate for the offense
most of the rest of the cases however so
those are the pretty clear-cut
ones and they're two two
okay the entire year
out of three million arrests two
that were clearly absolutely unjustified
um and then when you go on from there
you get to some cases that are
questionable not but questionable but
not quite as as
as clear-cut christopher whitfield was
shot allegedly
during a scuffle with police after
trying to steal from a convenience store
the sheriff's the sheriff's office
claims that uh the shooting was
accidental
police came they chased him there was a
scuffle and uh
and then and then whitfield was killed a
grand jury
cleared the officer of any criminal
wrongdoing in that case joseph
richardson of louisiana was shot by
officer vance matranga junior during a
no-knock raider
raid at a motel a budget seven motel
this was a drug raid they come in
richardson was unarmed he was shot in
the back of the head
deputies on the scene said that
richardson turned and reached for his
waistband
the officer in that case was not charged
with a crime officer giovanni crespo was
indicted for
aggravated manslaughter for shooting
gregory griffin during a car chase
crespo says that he thought griffin
pointed a gun at him um body cam footage
shows crespo actually
jumped out of his police cruiser on
multiple occasions somebody else was
driving
his partner was driving and fire
multiple shots at the fleeing vehicle
killing griffin eventually um officer
sung kim shot and killed jimmy atchison
while trying to arrest him for allegedly
stealing a a cell phone at gunpoint
atchison was backed into a broom closet
and then came out
and was killed okay
so there we have six shootings they
range from
outrageous the jefferson shooting to
questionable but these are still
only six out of the approximately three
million black suspects arrested in 2019.
half of the officers have been charged
with crimes so it's not as though cops
are given legal license to kill on a
whim
despite what we're told that's not the
case when you've got a clear-cut case of
a cop
murdering somebody or committing
manslaughter most of the time there's
going to be criminal charges
only one of these cases though is murder
two might be manslaughter you could
potentially make an argument for
manslaughter
in in in the other three cases though
the officers weren't charged or were
cleared
by comparison
48 police officers police officers were
victims of felony murder in the line of
duty during the same year
so you've got one felony murder of an
unarmed
black person and
48 felony murders of police officers in
the line of duty
and at any rate whatever you say about
whatever else you say about those six
cases in none of these cases is there
any reason whatsoever to suspect racial
bias
the last officer i mentioned wasn't even
white
um but there were 14 unarmed shootings
remember
so far we have accounted for six what
about the other eight
this is where the unarmed designation
really confuses matters and this is this
is the important part
we'll talk about it in just a second but
first the show today brought to you by
rock auto
you know there's no point in wasting
hours of your time uh getting into your
car
going to a auto parts store you don't
need to do it it's a waste of time
there's no reason for it rockauto.com is
just so much easier than walking into a
store
uh and then you know you're gonna get
questioned you're gonna have to have
quick answers for all of your questions
you're not gonna have time to look stuff
up if you need to
without being embarrassed anyway you
have to act this is why you have access
to rockauto.com
at your desk or in your pocket you just
pull it out pick it up
and um and you could solve all your
problems that way with your car
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market will
bear
they're going to give you the lowest
price they possibly can and you know you
can trust them because rockauto.com is a
family business they've been doing this
for a long time for 20 years
and you could go to rockauto.com to shop
for auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers
the rockauto.com catalog is unique very
easy to navigate you could quickly see
all the parts available for your car
or vehicle um and you could choose the
brands the specifications whatever you
have you can do it all there easy
affordable great selection what more can
you ask up for go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car
or truck write walsh in there how did
you hear about us box so that they know
that we sent you
okay 14 on arm shootings we talked about
six so far there are eight more
um and this is where
this is the really important part
because it shows that when you hear
unarmed person killed by police
many times perhaps most of the time at
least in 2019 this was the case
most of the time the person is not
really unarmed
melvin watkins was shot by a sheriff's
deputy
after watkins family called 9-1-1 to
report that he'd become violent
and they feared for their safety watkins
family was gathered in a home for some
sort of party some sort of gathering
they didn't want watkins to come because
they knew he was volatile and violent
apparently um
from what i understand he tried to get
into the house with it with a with a
screwdriver
they called police police came officers
arrived on the scene
at that point watkins allegedly tried to
run them over with his car
and was shot multiple witnesses and
video support this version of events
knoxville police officer dylan williams
was cleared of any wrongdoing by the d.a
after fatally shooting chinera phipp
last year
five eyewitnesses plus video evidence
and dash cam um footage
confirmed that phipp assaulted williams
choked him
grabbed his taser and used it on him and
then was killed
ryan twyman was shot by police
attempting to arrest him for possession
of illegal firearms in june of 2019.
um there's security camera footage of
this case too it shows twyman
uh they they they go to his apartment
complex they're looking to arrest him
illegal firearms um he's in his car
trying to get away they catch him in the
parking pad they're trying to get him
out of the car
and he starts to drive while one of the
officers
has his door open and it's trapped
behind his door so he's
he's driving and the officers is is
backing up quickly because he's trapped
behind the door
the other officer on the scene fearing
for his partner life's
partner's life opens fire and kills
twyman
um kevin pudlik
killed by police during a car chase the
driver of the car that public was in
public wasn't driving his
his friend or you know cohort
christopher lee calvin was driving
nearly pinned an officer between the car
and a concrete
wall at one point another point he was
gunning for an officer
um and the the other police officers on
the scene believe that he was
intentionally trying to hit them
cops on the scene finally opened fire
and uh
and and public was killed um
uh christopher lee calvin is the one
being charged with public's death not
the police officer
isaiah lewis uh call who the media would
call an
unarmed black teenager shot by police
only in this case he pounced on an
officer and knocked him
unconscious and at that point was shot
by another police officer
marcus mcveigh called by uh one
a local news article that i found
described him as a renowned criminal
um and i guess because he had a bevy of
of criminal
offenses you know a trap you know a rap
sheet as long as the bible including
assault on a public servant
he'd committed many crimes in the past
he was killed by police after assaulting
an officer during a foot chase
they tried to pull him over he got out
of the car ran into the woods he was
pursued
when the officer fought him into the
woods he assaulted the officer and was
shot in the struggle marzu scott
can be seen on body cam footage
attacking a female police officer was
trying to arrest him after he assaulted
a store clerk
moments before the footage clearly shows
that the officer was knocked to the
ground by scott and that she tried to
use a taser but that didn't stop him and
she had no choice but to resort to her
firearm
finally kevin mason of baltimore was
shot by police responding to a domestic
violence call
a woman in the house feared for her
safety because of kevin mason called the
police the police show up mason
sent dogs after the officers when that
didn't scare them off
mason called 9-1-1 threatened to blast
them quote unquote and
quote kill every last one of them
talking about the police officers
then when mason emerged from his house a
second time an officer
justifiably believing mason to be a
lethal threat because he said he was a
lethal threat
opened fire they didn't find any firearm
in the house when they looked later
whose fault is that
you you called 9-1-1 and say i'm going
to kill all these police officers and
come out of your house
you're going to get shot now
so those are the other eight no
reasonable person
could describe no reasonable person
could describe
any of the eight cases i just listed as
cold-blooded murder
much less racist murder these were
violent criminals who were shot
in most cases while in the act of
physically attacking
and threatening the lives of police
officers
none of them were truly unarmed either
some of them were using cars
one used a dog others used their their
hands and nearly succeeded in arming
themselves with the officer's weapon
this is what the media and blm activists
mean when they scream about the epidemic
of unarmed black men being killed by
police
they mean that a very tiny fraction of
black people arrested by police are
killed in the process
a very tiny fraction and that an even
tinier fraction are unarmed at the time
and that an even tinier fraction of that
fraction of the fraction
actually had no weapon of any kind
because the majority of the unarmed
did in fact have weapons it just they
don't count as weapons
um in the official reports and the media
don't count them as weapons either
now when you look at it like that it
doesn't seem like there's much of an
epidemic here at all does there
in fact there are a couple other things
that you you think when you read about
these cases
number one
i think again if you're reasonable which
is a big if these
days you come away very impressed with
police officers
for the incredible restraint they so
often
use that um the body cam footage of the
the female police officer for example
perp is a perfect example of this she's
trying to apprehend a man who's violent
and
in a danger to others he assaulted a
store clerk the clerk the clerk called
the police what else
are you gonna do the officer is like
pleading with this man
to just listen she does everything she
possibly can
putting her putting her own life on the
line
to preserve this man's life she does not
run up hoping to kill somebody
this is not how most police officers
operate
um she only finally resorted to lethal
force because she had no choice
because the violent criminal gave her no
choice
he was determined either he's going to
die or she is
that's the way he was looking at this
why i mean what was the point he
he assaulted a police a store clerk for
for no reason why do you have to do that
and then the police show up you know it
i mean i think that should be a felony
but these days he probably wouldn't even
been charged with a felony for it he
probably would have gotten off with a
misdemeanor all he had to do was
cooperate
he did commit a crime after all but it's
not like it's unreasonable for the
police to show
up and and and try to arrest him what
else are you gonna do he assaulted
someone they're gonna say ah you're fine
go go for it
this man did everything in his power to
get himself killed
and this as you can see is pretty common
in these cases
and most of the time the officers
do everything they can the other officer
the one uh i think it was the isaiah
lewis
[Music]
case that officer there
was so reluctant to use lethal force
that he got knocked unconscious thank
god the other
there was another officer nearby to save
his life what do you think isaiah lewis
is going to do after he knocks the
police officer unconscious
what do you think he's going to do next
you know put a blanket on him and and
tell him night night no he's going to
kill him
um but that officer so reluctant to use
lethal force doing everything he can
that he that he ends up getting knocked
unconscious in the process
i mean he should have used lethal force
earlier didn't
so that's what you take away from this
is actually being very impressed with
the restraint that police officers
usually show um and when there's a
police officer
who is is way on the other end of the
spectrum
who has an outrageous lack of restraint
that is pretty damn rare
and in those cases there's uh
you know universal condemnation and
those officers end up going to jail most
of the time
just like the officer that shot
jefferson is probably going to go to
jail as well he should
one other quick thing that you take from
this is uh when you when you hear about
these cases
what do you think is going to happen
when we defund police
who's responding to these calls in these
calls that you know
the eight that i just read especially
most of the time
these are you know relatively
uh run-of-the-mill
they they begin as run-of-the-mill uh
calls
for police you know a domestic violence
thing unfortunately that's
run-of-the-mill
uh shouldn't be but it is um
trying to pull someone over for a
traffic violation
you know just responding to an assault
or a scuffle or something like that just
run-of-the-mill cops show up turns into
a deadly encounter
just like that and not because the cops
want it to but because
the criminal the violent criminal has
decided to take it there
what are you going to do if they're not
what are you going to have social
workers what's going to happen
all those officers the uh in the isaiah
lewis case
let's say those were social workers
responding and not officers
rather than having one dead violent
criminal of
by the name of isaiah lewis we'd
probably have about four or five dead
social workers
so when you look at the actual facts you
see that the leftist narrative
across the board utterly falls apart
which is why we have to look at the
facts and not take their word for it
okay now we're gonna go to five
headlines
[Music]
five headlines sponsored by benham
brothers learn how to own a business
without it owning you get a 15
discount on the better brothers new
course expert ownership at
benhambrothers.com
walsh so uh representative yoho of
florida a few days ago got into a bit of
a heated exchange with representative
alexandria quezo cortez
outside of the um capitol building in
washington and in this exchange yoho was
mad at cortez for specifically for some
of the stuff she's been saying about the
rioting and chaos and the violence
and how she tried to claim that all this
is happening because people just want
bread for their families
and um he said riojo said to cortez
you're out of your freaking mind
um which well you can see why he would
think that and then she called him rude
and
as they left parted ways yoho said of
cortez
but i don't think to her but said it
sort of under his breath as he walked
away
effing b word only he didn't say
ethic b word he said the words
themselves that was overheard by a
reporter so you may not believe it but
we should note that yoho was asked about
it and his response was no comment
and then the guy he was walking with
another lawmaker
was asked what happened and here's here
was his response he said
i was actually thinking as i was walking
down the stairs i was thinking about
some issues i've got in my district that
need to get done
i don't know what their topic was
there's always a topic isn't there
so that's a good that's a good friend
folks that's uh he ain't snitching
um i just love that his excuse is that
he didn't hear the argument because he
was just so
immersed in thinking about his district
and wanting to help the the folks back
home
um so you know totally believable of
course great stuff there
now this is all a setup to tell you
about
the only part of this that concerns
anyone really
cortez decided to spend time on the
floor of the house
pandemic going on chaos in the street
country
in turmoil she decides to waste
taxpayers time
on the house floor complaining about the
mean words that someone said
to her uh here she is i walked back
out and there were reporters in the
front of the capitol
and in front of reporters representative
yoho called me
and i quote
these are the words that representative
yoho
levied against a congresswoman
the congresswoman that not only
represents new york's 14th congressional
district
but every congresswoman and every woman
in this country
because all of us have had to deal with
this
in some form some way some shape
at some point in our lives this issue
is not about one incident it is
cultural it is a culture of lack of
impunity
of accepting of violence and violent
language
against women an entire structure of
power
that supports that and that went on for
almost 10 minutes
get over it he said a bad word this
isn't 9 11 okay it's not a national
tragedy we don't need your 10 minute
speech about someone saying something
mean to you
this doesn't concern anyone but the two
people involved
no one else cares why should anyone else
care what possible relevance is it
you guys got into an argument he called
you a bad word okay hey you know
sorry i what do you want
and no yoho was not using abusive
language towards women you know she's
trying to turn this into an attack on
all
it's not an attack on all women he
wasn't abusing he wasn't using abusive
language towards
towards women he was using abusive
language towards one particular woman it
was an attack
on one it was a personal attack on one
particular individual it was not an
attack on all women everywhere
a personal attack and that's relevant
because
personal attack means deal with it on
your own time
deal with it on your personal time go
talk to him and tell him that he hurts
your feelings
that's fine it's it's not something that
everyone needs to hear about
i mean this this this whole thing that
we get especially from liberal women
anytime they're insulted or attacked
this is an
assault on all women everywhere no it's
not he just doesn't like you
i'm not defending what he said not
saying it was the right thing to say
but this concerns you and him you're not
a representative for all women
everywhere
in fact i'm guessing that well over half
the women in the country
or at least half uh would would would
say that
you don't quite represent them or their
values i i i feel pretty safe
saying that there are millions of women
in this country who do not consider
alexandria queso cortez to be a
representative of them
and then and then of course you know she
she during this soliloquy she uh
proceeds to act as though you know th
this this never happens to men
you know this this happens to women far
too often we get yeah okay
you know men get insulted too all the
time okay men get called
sexually degrading names also um
and uh you know it's even actually more
acceptable in society to do that so
it really happens to everybody not a
huge deal
deal with it on your own time um
number two president trump at a press
conference yesterday said something that
people of course are upset about as
usual but
tell me what's wrong with this take a
listen if schools do not reopen
the funding should go to parents to send
their child to public private charter
religious or
home school of their choice the key word
being choice
yeah you want to talk about defunding
things well if it's if
there is a certain service that the
government refused refuses to render
then we shouldn't be funding that
service money shouldn't be going
i shouldn't be paying for a service that
the government will not provide
now as a homeschool parent and a
taxpayer i'm already paying for
educational services that i don't use
which is bad enough as it is but
if if it's a service that no one can use
because the government refuses to fully
provide it
then it shouldn't be funded we shouldn't
have to pay for it i think that's pretty
simple
number three a horrible case in florida
three friends out on a fishing trip were
murdered
um by a man named tony wiggins tony t.j
wiggins wiggins had two accomplices but
it seems that he's the one who
led this thing and pulled the trigger
now this is pretty chilling
um there's cctv footage not of the
murder but
of what happened ten minutes before okay
damien tillman one of the victims
along with two of his friends were
killed on a fishing trip um
ran into a convenience store on the way
to uh you know to their fishing spot
pick up a few things and there uh
tillman ran into wiggins
and they had an exchange and you would
think that okay
this is going to be an exchange of them
having an argument or some kind of
uh fight or something and then that led
to violence
but no that's actually not what happened
watch this you know you can't hear what
they're saying but you can see the
exchange there
so you see this is appears to be and uh
i believe the store clerk
confirmed just a friendly conversation
they're having
um they had a friendly exchange no
argument completely polite and normal
or so it seemed but as tillman left
wiggins and his brother and
uh his girlfriend followed them
in their truck tracked them to a spot in
the woods where they were going and then
murdered all three
of them apparently there was some story
wiggins had about how one of the friends
had
stolen a car engine or
something like that um that was the
pretense for the murder
i don't know if there's any evidence
that any theft occurred not that it
matters at all
this was cold-blooded execution for no
real reason
now here's the point to take home from
this aside from how evil and tragic it
is
wiggins had 230 felonies
no that's not i'm not misreading that
230
felonies on his record 15 convictions
had already been to state prison twice
and many of his convictions were for
violent crimes
these weren't all drug crimes okay these
were assaulting police officers
assaulting the elderly
among others and yet here is this
scumbag this evil
satanic filth out again
on bond i believe and he murders three
people
so you know i say again we talk about
criminal justice reform oh we need
criminal justice reform
we do need criminal justice reform but
that is reform that keeps dangerous
criminals in prison
that's the real problem we have with our
justice system it's not that
a bunch of innocent people are going to
jail now that does happen but it's not
happening on a large scale i'll tell you
what is happening on a large scale
dangerous parasites
are sent to prison because they commit
you know violent crime and then are let
go
and then they commit another crime let
go again commit another crime
they just keep they they keep filtering
their back into the community
until eventually they do something so
horrible that now the system has no
choice but to keep them behind bars
you shouldn't get 15 chances okay
number four america magazine which is a
jesuit publication has this article
today
uh an article which proves my point that
all jesuits should be excommunicated
um the article is uh
the article's titled the crucifixion of
george floyd
yes crucifixion of george floyd let me
give you a little sampling a little
morsel of this it says the parallels
between particulars of
the crucifixion most familiar to us as a
report of the new testament and that of
george floyd are haunting
it no it's not haunting because there
are no parallels there are
zero parallels but let's see the
argument they make here
it should be stressed at the outset that
in 3380 crucifixion was not reserved for
those who claimed to be the son of god
or the king of the jews
or who posed other threats to civil
authority it was
the great show no mercy lesson to
thieves murderers and other criminals
the authorities wanted to punish
in the most aggravating way possible
jesus was laid on the ground to be
nailed to the cross
george floyd was laid down on the ground
and pinned by derrick shoven's knee on
his neck
as time passed jesus suffered from
thirst george floyd asked for water
both jesus and george floyd were
repeatedly mocked by their killers
jesus cried out to his father and george
floyd called for his mother
shortly before he lost consciousness he
said i'm through i'm through
in other words it is finished
the story of christ's crucifixion was
not written down for almost half a
century in our time to a great credit
the crucifixion of george floyd was
instantaneously touched and galvanized
the nation and beyond
daddy changed the world his six-year-old
daughter said at the funeral service for
george floyd in houston texas sam cook's
great civil rights anthem
a change is going to come rang out
seeing it through
all the way whatever it takes now falls
to us
the living i mean this is
i mean what else can be said about this
kind of thing that i haven't already
said
um literal
literal canonization and more of george
floyd
and by the way i know i have to i
shouldn't have to tell this is a
you know supposed to be a christian
magazine but these are jesuits so i do
have to
say that uh george floyd when he said
i'm through i'm through yeah he meant
i'm gonna die when when jesus said
it is finished he meant his
saving act was finished so this had a
much deeper meaning than just
i'm going to die and
many other differences as well i
that's just one one difference between
the crucifixion of jesus christ our lord
and savior
and the death of george floyd
which i i think has been well
established by now was
is a sad thing and unjust
um and fortunately it's
it's in the courts now it's in it's in
the hands of the court as it should be
all of that is true it's also true that
george floyd was
uh not a good man to put it mildly this
was a man who
um forced his way into a woman's home
robbed her at gunpoint in her home in
front of her child
it unspeakably violent
evil act george floyd committed among
other crimes
does that mean that he deserved to die
no okay
but it does mean that we should be very
reluctant
to canonize him or turn him into jesus
christ
or you know to to memorialize him in a
way
that celebrates the man he was because
there's not a lot to celebrate there
so it requires a certain restraint that
i think a lot of people these days are
not
capable of um if you're capable of just
saying
he didn't deserve to die this was a
terrible thing
and you want to leave it at that fine
agreed
you start going into this nonsense okay
now we have an issue and now it becomes
necessary to bring up that oh by the way
this was a man who
committed a horrible act against a woman
um
again among other crimes number five
finally a swarm of bees uh descended
onto a beach in new jersey
this is b news you know i have to have
to hit it the the the
bees gathered on the back of a chair
about a beach towel
so there's the picture of it and here's
a local news report about this incident
watch
new video showing a different kind of
beach overcrowding in cape may
that big brown blob on the back of the
beach chair
is a swarm of bees the stinging insects
stormed the sand yesterday they were
swarming around until they landed on a
towel a beekeeper wrapped them
in a towel placed them in a box and word
is around there that the bees took
flight when somebody knocked the queen
out of her nearby nest so you mess with
the queen
you mess with them that's right and you
see there that's why
when we talk about first responders we
should be talking about beekeepers too
i've always said this my community we
are also first responders we are the
first people who are called in any be
related emergency
and we save many lives every year
thousands of lives
mostly bee lives but but still lives our
lives all right
we're all equal i believe that
and can i just say also there's there's
some misinformation in that report um
they didn't swarm because someone
knocked the queen out of a nest all
right
bees swarm when the original hive is
overcrowded so the queen will take about
you know a third or so of
the workers they go off to start a new
hive they were looking for a new home
that's that's why they were there okay
they had every right to be there
just like anybody else on the beach
uh the bees at the old hive will appoint
a new queen and actually they well they
don't
they select a few larvae um and they
convert them into
into queens by feeding them royal jelly
which is the substance they secrete from
their
from their heads and uh and then
whichever queen
emerges will then go and murder the
other baby queens
seizing power and beginning her reign of
terror and that's the whole reason i
like bees really because i can relate so
much
um to to that and to their experiences
in general in many ways so a little bit
of b
news that's good let's go to our daily
cancellation
before we do you know if you haven't
gotten your readers passed yet from
dailywire.com you got a good you got to
do that dailywire.com
subscribe uh it's hard to get the real
story these days without the leftist
spin uh very difficult to do
and if you want to make sure that you
always have access to great op-eds to
great analysis
interesting insights exclusive op-eds
from your podcast host as well as
guest writers in-depth analysis from our
daily wire reporters all of that
you got to get go to dailywire.com
subscribe and get the reader's pass
usually it's three dollars a month but
we're starting it now at 99 cents a
month so
you know less than a dollar a month
hard to beat that you can't beat it
really mobile ad free access to all of
our daily wire news exclusive op-eds all
of our podcasts plus you can join the
community
of daily wire members who uh comment on
and discuss
all of these articles so head over to
dailywire.com
subscribe and join today okay today for
our daily cancellation i will be
canceling
the football team in washington
and i'll explain why um
first of all you know that in this
cultural moment that we currently are in
um where the racist origins of of
many things of everything is finally
coming to bear
we talked a few days ago about the
racist origins for example of sleep
okay sleeping is systemically racist i
don't know if you knew that
so in that environment naming or
renaming a sports team
is a hazardous pursuit that that must be
handled with the utmost care
um this is gonna be very difficult to do
without being racist
obviously the professional sports team
in washington had to get rid of the
redskins name
it was deeply offensive to white
liberals and even a few native americans
perhaps
but the fear was always here was my
great fear and i think i said this this
is a case that i made
okay get rid of the name i'm worried
that
the new name might be more dehumanizing
than the old
that's the thought that's kept me up at
night and finally
my nightmare scenario has become a
reality
espn reports that the team formerly
called the redskins will at least for
the 2020 season officially called itself
the washington football team that's the
new name at least for now
and their logo is just a red background
with yellow letters that says
the washington football team established
1932.
now needless to say when i saw this for
the first time
i vomited um
what what they had before was merely
degrading racist and offensive
this new name is traumatizing
to a nearly lethal extent i almost died
when i first saw this
first of all let's go through the
problems here
right off the bat obvious one here
washington was a slave owner
his name should not be found on a
football helmet or anywhere else on
earth
also the word foot is inherently
otherwising to those who identify as
disabled
it invalidates their lived experience
and it relegates them further to the
fringes of mainstream society
the word ball obviously brings to mind
anti-trans
stereotypes not to mention it
marginalizes those who
marginalizes those who identify as
two-dimensional
now it's hard to even know where to
begin with it with a slur like
team i can't believe that it's the year
2020 and
anyone is calling themselves a team
which for one thing is an anagram for
meat so are we just pretending that
vegans don't exist now so we're just
erasing their existence also
also the concept of team has sexist and
patriarchal roots evoking a time when
women
were not able to participate in team
sports because they were considered too
fragile and weak
now 1932
so you think you know we've we've it
it's bad enough washington football team
um that's the worst part no 1932 perhaps
the most atrociously offensive aspect of
the entire revamped logo
remember that arabic numerals were
appropriated from arab culture
and now they bring to mind the west's
history of colonization and violence
against
black and brown bodies um 1932 also
happens to be the same year that charles
lindbergh was kidnapped
making the memorialization of this year
very traumatizing
for trafficking victims
and of course as as everybody knows i
have to tell you 1932 is also the year
that mahatma gandhi began his hunger
strike against the british new cast
separation laws
which is an event that hindus still
solemnly remember and celebrate today i
assume
by claiming 1932 on their logo
washington is ruthlessly appropriating
from indian culture
and erasing gandhi's legacy at the same
time
now on the plus side of course the great
depression did impoverish a lot of white
people in 1932
so that's good but it's not nearly
enough to balance everything out here
if washington wants to pick a name that
will not minimize
marginalize otherwise dehumanize
patronize problematize criticize
villainize or vaporize any protected
class or minority group
it could go with something like the
saris
with a mascot of a tearful white man
prostrating himself and humiliated
submission
okay that would be good if they're not
ready to take a very socially conscious
step like that then i think the next
best option would be a name that is
nothing more than incomprehensible
sounds mixed together like um
you know i mean really anything just as
long as it's not a real word just uh
like the the the the ah foosh
migli ers um
for example or even uh the flinders
shins you know
which i kind of like actually now that
the flundershins has a has a ringtone
just something that there's no there's
no word it's not associated with
anything
and then people can create their own
associations with it
really anything would be better than the
old name or the new one
though i fear that whatever name they
ultimately choose
whatever it is the emotional damage
has already been done
and so that's why they are canceled
with great prejudice we'll leave it
there for the week
uh something for us all to think about
and reflect on
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
godspeed
the matt wall show was produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright
daily wire 20 20. if you prefer facts
over feelings aren't offended by the
brutal truth and you can still laugh at
the insanity filling our national news
cycle
well tune in to the ben shapiro show
we'll get a whole lot of that and much
more
see you there